things are on the up and up for justin
and hayley bieber
a source tells et that the couple is
quote doing very well after they both
experienced health scares this year as
you can see this eye is not blinking
full paralysis in the side of my face
in june justin revealed to his fans that
he had temporary facial paralysis after
being diagnosed with ramsay hunt
syndrome
an announcement that came two months
after his wife haley revealed she had to
undergo heart surgery not long after
doctors found a blood clot in her brain
definitely the scariest moment of my
life basically it's like having a mini
stroke it was definitely a really
eye-opening thing for me i definitely
felt
a lot of anxiety through the situation
following those traumatic experiences a
source now tells e.t that the beavers
are ready to put those health scares
behind them
saying quote they are very attached to
one another and want to be there for
each other and support each other
haley is very much of a caretaker and
justin loves that about her when they're
apart they're always checking in on each
other quote they are closer than ever
and the best part about their
relationship is that they don't have to
try and make it work it just comes so
naturally to them
they are very grateful for that and so
glad that quote justin is feeling better
and getting back to his regular self
it's an amazing feeling speaking of
justin feeling better we are seeing that
firsthand et can confirm that he is
officially resuming his justice world
tour on july 31st after putting it on
hold following his diagnosis
another sign that the two are moving
forward over the weekend the couple
stunned as they attended filmmaker
michael ratner's wedding
justin captioned the photos on instagram
quote i love you baby it's a good part
and uh i love him
speaking of michael ratner he's directed
many of justin's projects including his
documentary series justin bieber seasons
that captured his and haley's wedding
[Music]
in 2020 et spoke with the director and
he shared what he's taken away from the
solid bond that the singer and model
have created between one another
i think it's really nice that they've
been friends for as long as they've been
there's
tremendous history there uh and i think
that they're meant to be i mean they've
got a fantastic relationship uh i think
that she's obviously a tremendous wife
and and they're working on uh being a
really you know strong
unit yeah and i think he's he's working
on being and is a great uh husband and
she's there to make sure that he's got
what he needs and he's taken care of and
um it goes both ways though it really
that's a phenomenal two-way relationship
[Music]
you